welcome back to a20 special relativity
so we're starting a new chapter in which
we look at tests and implications of
special relativity
um we started the entire discussion
um integration of neurons
transformations and the description of
the paradoxes
based on einstein's postulates
those are not axioms which means that we
do actually have to verify um they are a
prediction of how nature functions and
experimental verification is needed to
gain confidence
that those
postulates are actually correct or
realized in nature
and we have studied some of those tests
already and this serves as a little bit
of a review
of the discussions we have this to this
point
one experimental test is stellar
aberration which we discussed can be
explained by special relativity and by
velocity addition so this gives us some
idea about what light is
um
light
is a trippy is being tested in a variety
of different
experiments starting from michaels and
morley which basically tests that the
speed of light is independent of the
orientation of the apparatus
we have not discussed in detail
another experiment which is very similar
is the canadian thorndike experiment
which tests that the speed of light is
also independent of the velocity of the
apparatus itself
as one of the homework assignments we
looked at
the sitter who tested that the speed of
light is independent
of the speed of the source
and that has been tested for example
with the motion of binary stars as we
did in our pset in our homework
assignment
we can look in particle physics the
decay of a pion into two photons and
those pions they can have a lot of
energy
for example with a better of 0.999 times
speed of light and still the photons out
of this decay they behave like any other
photons they move with the speed of
light
then we discussed the doppler effect and
relativistic doppler effect and
analyzed
light um with various frequencies
and one of the hypotheses you could have
is that the photon actually is a massive
particle
this would directly modify coulomb's
laws which are tested
experimentally
and those results would be dependent on
the frequency um it is weird
electromagnetic effect if you introduce
a mass to the photons like torque on a
magnetic ring
again here precision measurements have
been performed and they're all in
agreement with the hypothesis that the
photon is massless
and we talked about the doppler shift in
redshift
for light
another class of experiment is where we
look directly at time
dilation for example
in the decay of the muon as we discussed
we have cosmic neurons to study or we
can produce neurons in the laboratory as
well and study them or we can put very
precise clocks on planes um fly them
around the globe and compare them
with stationary and and
simply measure the effect of special
relativity on those blocks
in all of this experimentation and
experimental verification it's important
to understand the importance of
uncertainties and the scientific process
overall
um
i think that you know in his women has a
historic perspective on on science one
often forgets
that specific measurement comes with an
uncertainty
often the statistical uncertainty
or systematic effects which are quite
important to
quantify the level of
verification of the theoretical
hypothesis
one example here is and experiments can
have biases as well and one example of a
biased experiment is here one from by
walter kaufman who tried to measure e
over m the electric charge over the mass
of the electron
but he had a rather strong theoretical
bias and he conducted the experiment at
the time einstein was proposing his
theory
um you know
the bias really came from the model of
an electron at the time
and his experiments
were not inc were inconsistent with
einstein so he said einstein is wrong
einstein and lawrence are wrong um
blanc looked at this and said maybe but
einstein's conclusion immediately by
looking at this was you know this cannot
be
and it took a little bit of of time to
clear up those experiments until 1914.
um you can read more about this in this
wikipedia article about walter kaufman's
experiment
but let me just read this to you the
prevalent results
decide they speak against the
correctness of lawrence assumptions as
well as einstein's if an account
of that one considers this basic
assumption refuted so one would be
forced to consider it a failure to
attempt to base an entire field of
physics including electrodynamics and
optics upon the principle
of relative movement
we now know this was wrong but you know
scientific process
happens in
uh in scientific environment and i
started
this class by explaining that one needs
to be open-minded to uh to learn and to
study and to grow
scientifically and then have to question
the assumptions understand assumptions
when they go into measurements
so this is the first part of this
chapter where we talk about
tests
we will have a discussion of
implications of special relativity as we
move on from here